it is the 8th March of its kind through
Central London Calling for an end to the
war on Gaza protesters now filling White
Hall listening to speeches on the edge
of parliament square right at the the
seat of government here and in that the
message clearly aimed as much at the
government in Israel to pressure it to
end its war on Gaza as it is aimed at
the British government to end its
support for Israel and its war on Gaza
it's very important to keep the pressure
on the on the UK government because
they're one of the supporters the
enablers of this genocide and without
the UK the US the EU supports Israel
cannot do anything an Eclectic mix of
groups and organizations represented
here calling for a ceasefire now but
also people I've spoken to expressing
their concern and alarm at the possible
implications in the region of of this
war the potential for it spilling out
and affecting other countries and
remember this is the first March since
the international court of justice in
the ha last month issued its preliminary
judgment calling on Israel to Halt any
actions that could lead to genocide
that's represented here as well I can
stand watching my phone and seeing how
many people are being killed and how a
genocide is happening and how the the
world leaders are doing doing anything a
low-key police presence of around a
thousand officers policing this March
but warning that overt signs of
anti-jewish sentiment or indeed pro-
Hamas sentiment may be faced with arrest
the crowd now though overwhelmingly
peaceful jahal Al jazer
London make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer